i think i figured out why the economy is
in total collapse and most people are
much poorer than we were three years ago
turns out the biden administration
doesn't know anything about business
and i don't mean that in a cheap
political shot kind of way i mean that
in a quantifiable
indisputable kind of way a new report
from the committee to unleash prosperity
has just revealed that the top 68
officials in the biden administration
have spent an average
of 2.4 years in the business world these
are the top guys in the administration
2.4 years of those 68 people
just eight of them can claim extensive
business experience and gets even better
the median length of business experience
among biden's top officials
is
zero
zero years
now i am not one of those people who
thinks that the government should be run
exactly like a business i don't think
that the government is not a business
there is more to politics than just
profits and efficiency and gdp
but don't you think the people running
our country should know
something
about how the economy actually works
have some practical first-hand
experience with it
our last president had spent his whole
career in business and he hired lots of
business people
and what do you know they spent their
time making america's business run
better
our current president has spent his
entire career in left-wing politics and
he's hired lots of leftist ideologues
and what do you know they spend their
time trying to expand abortion and trans
all the kids and watch the economy
completely collapse none of this should
come as any surprise personnel is policy
and as long as these people are running
the show
do not expect things to improve i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from janelle
austring who says i cracked up because
when michael was mid-sentence i got a
firehouse subs ad that said try our
favorite italian
either the ads the targeted ads from the
social media algorithms are getting much
much better or that's a little wink of
providence you know all nature is but
art unknown to the all chance direction
which that can't not see maybe it's a
little bit of both i am so excited that
today i'm going to be able to hear from
you not just in my favorite comment of
the day but in the mail bag especially
in the voicemail bag who brings us the
voicemail bag you know it's pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com enter promo
code knowles podcast do this right now
you are getting pinched we are all
getting pinched at the gas tank when we
go buy groceries why are we getting
pinched because of all the terrible
policies that are causing everything to
skyrocket in price
except for your cell phone bill if you
switch to pure talk you're probably
spending what 80 90 a month for your
cell phone plan what if i told you you
could get the exact same extremely high
quality service talk text plenty of data
for 30 bucks a month i am a pure talk
customer the 5g coverage is great it's a
veteran-owned company customer service
is right here in the u.s i know it's
always scary to switch your cell phone
you think it's going to be a hassle you
never want to do it it's so simple at
puretalk and you will save so much money
they make it really easy there's a no
risk money-back guarantee go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code knowles podcast to save 50 off your
first month by the way talk sponsors the
voice mail bag as though you didn't
already have reason enough they are
bringing you the wonderful voice mail
bag so head on over
you can switch over to pure talk in less
than 10 minutes promo code knowles
podcast can or
w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com
every day i feel like this is my opening
every single day and it's because every
single day things get even worse for joe
biden we keep talking about the lowest
approval ratings ever actually scratch
that and now the lowest approval ratings
ever actually scratch that there's a new
poll out from yahoo news and yougov
that shows that
i'll ask you before i don't want to give
it away yet what percentage of americans
do you think want joe biden to run for
re-election this is all americans but
this is the guy who allegedly was
elected with more votes than ever in the
whole history of democracy
what percentage of americans want the
incumbent president to run for
re-election
what would you guess maybe you'd say i
don't know if things are bad 40
things are really bad 30 percent
18
18 of americans less than one in five
americans wants the president to run for
re-election yahoo describes this as the
lowest number to date
this reflects a seven point drop a seven
percentage point drop from the number of
americans who wanted him to run for
reelection
in may that was two months ago and
even worse news perhaps for biden even
worse than the people turning on him and
the people not wanting him to run for
re-election
cnn doesn't seem to want him to run for
re-election either anderson cooper ran a
devastating segment on cnn about biden
we've decided to release the kraken
tonight
joining me is our favorite and only cnn
senior data reporter harry enton how
does prison biden stack up against other
presidents at this time in
administrations
yeah so you can look at both joe biden's
disapproval rating on inflation and joe
biden's disapproval rating overall and
what we see is his his disapproval
rating on inflation is topping 70
percent his disapproval rating overall
is still in the 50s but if you compare
that to every single other president at
this point in their first term
throughout polling history this goes all
the way back since the 1940s he is the
worst on both and the reason he is the
worst overall is because inflation is
eating his presidency alive at this
point
am i watching the daily wire am i
watching the michael knowles show oh no
i'm watching cnn and anderson cooper but
they are being harsher toward biden than
sometimes even i am than the right-wing
media are why is this
it's not a complicated issue it's
because the libs not just the the
regular rank-and-file lib voters but the
liberal leaders and the liberal
intellectuals and liberal communicators
they all know that biden is a dead man
walking they know his presidency is a
disaster and they know that in a fair
election his odds of of winning
reelection are the odds of a snowball in
hell so they realize gosh we've got to
change course we need some new candidate
we need him to not run for reelection we
need him to get behind some other
candidate
who that candidate is we don't know
kamala harris would probably be a
disaster buddha judge is never going to
happen maybe gavin newsom maybe some
candidate that we're not even aware of
yet but whatever it is we can't have
biden these numbers are just abysmal and
it gives republicans a huge opportunity
and this is where things get really
spicy and saucy because the republicans
have what would appear to be the most
winnable election
maybe in my lifetime that they've got in
front of them but there's this big wild
card there is this big elephant in the
room a big lion in the room if you ask
me
mr coffee himself donald trump will
trump run or not
if you believe the polls take them with
a grain of salt of course
trump
does not do very well against a democrat
against joe biden or other democrats
compared to other candidates who've been
floated such as ron desantis
again that may be true that may not be
true i don't believe those polls at the
moment i just think one it's too early
and two i don't i don't really trust the
libs
when they're when it comes to donald
trump in particular because they hate
this guy and the fact that they hate
this guy so much is one of the reasons
that i like the guy so much a
liberal magazine new york magazine just
did an interview with trump
and according to the magazine they seem
to suggest that trump is going to run in
2024.
the the interviewer asked him when are
you going to make a decision and he said
i've already made my decision
that's done i've already made my
decision
but again that's kind of ambiguous
does that mean he's decided he's not
going to run but he's going to keep
leading people on to believe that he's
going to run so that he can maintain
some influence in the party what
but then later on in the interview the
interviewer says he kind of loosened up
and he made clear he is running and he
said the only question now is do i
declare before the midterms or after the
midterms
again the way i'm reading his literal
words
i think he still leaves himself some
ambiguity but if people were taking bets
today i it would be it would be very
hard to make the case that it seems like
trump is not running
he is doing and saying
everything that someone would do or say
if he were running for president and
he's got every reason to run
he feels he was jilted the last time he
didn't get to complete his second term
he's still extremely popular he's
leading the field by what 40 points now
the only thing cutting against him is
his age and i know it's popular now to
say that
older people should not run for
president i don't i don't think there
should be an age cut off elon musk
recently said no one over the age of 69
should run for president and i think it
was mostly because he wanted to make a
joke about the number 69 but i don't
think that's true i think it's entirely
dependent on the person ronald reagan
famously said he's not going to make age
an issue of his campaign and he's not
going to exploit for political purposes
his uh his opponent's relative youth and
inexperience ronald reagan was the
oldest man we had ever elected president
and he's one of the best presidents in
recent american history and so it's
entirely dependent on the person joe
biden is now the oldest man who's ever
been elected president and he doesn't
know his own name and he doesn't know
what end is up so i think you've got to
you've got to make that calculation not
based on some arbitrary number but on
the man and if you look at donald trump
love him or hate him the guy is still
totally with it he's still totally full
of energy he's campaigning like a much
much younger candidate even now he's
going out and campaigning for midterm
candidates and he he was he was asked
about age during the 2020 race and he
said look
listen i don't know if biden's too old
i'll just tell you i am so young i'm a
young vibrant man and he he acts that
way i don't know if it's because he
doesn't drink i don't know if it's
because he's mostly aspartame and fast
food preservatives now but i don't know
if it's good genes whatever it is the
guy is very energetic and if he runs
he seems likely to win the primary i
don't think it's inevitable i think if a
desantis ran or if a different candidate
ran i think they would have a chance in
the primary but again just looking at
the numbers just looking at the name
recognition just knowing the candidate
if trump runs
he's very likely to win the primary
and so if you don't want trump to be the
nominee and if you feel that trump is
going to lose the general election
all of your energy has to be focused
right now on stopping him from running
for president
and i know there are a lot of
conservatives who
either they hated trump then they like
trump they hate trump again or they
liked trump from the beginning but
they're sick and tired of trump or they
really like trump but they think look
trump's just not going to win
re-election so we got to move on to
somebody else
i am open to all of these possibilities
i am not committed to any particular
2024 primary outcome right now i know
some people have already picked their
horse i have not i say let the chips
fall where they may let the process play
out i really really like trump he's my
favorite former president alive today i
love i love desantis desantis is the
best governor around today i like a lot
of other candidates who potentially
could throw their hats in the ring from
other segments of the political order i
say let the process play out but you are
seeing that primary already taking place
and the clearest place you're seeing it
is in the feud between trump
and elon musk
now
when you want to protect yourself not
just your party not just your country
but your home you got to check out ring
right now go to ring.com
knowles summer is here you're probably
going to be away from your home for long
stretches of time though even if you're
in your home you want to be safe no
matter where you are you want to protect
that home the physical home your
property your family your digital home
your data that's why you need ring
everyone knows about rings video
doorbell where you get to see and speak
to whoever's at your doorstep from
wherever you are in the world a lot of
people know about ring alarm that is
rings award winning alarm system not as
many people
know about ring alarm pro you got to be
a pro baby when it comes to security
when it comes to your home your stuff
your family of course you got to be a
pro be like me become a pro cnet calls
ring alarm pro a giant leap for home
security because you're monitoring not
just your doors and your windows and all
that stuff you're also monitoring your
digital home your data we spend so much
of our lives in the digital virtual
space you've got to protect that you may
not have known about it but it is true
ring has an award-winning alarm system
this busy summer season protect your
home gopro with ring alarm pro learn
more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
the primary for 2024 for the republicans
is playing at not with snipes between
trump and ron desantis or snipes between
trump and ted cruz or trump snipes
between trump and mike pompeo or nikki
haley or whoever
the the 2024 primary right now is
playing out between trump and elon musk
why people are saying why why are these
two social media genius billionaires why
are they going at it because elon musk
is an avatar for ron desantis
the the elon trump feud
has uh been just continuing in recent
days and
elon has said about trump
i don't hate the man but it's time for
trump to hang up his hat and sail into
the sunset dems should also call off the
attack don't make it so that trump's
only way to survive is to regain the
presidency trump would be 82 at the end
of his term which is too old to be chief
executive of anything let alone the
united states of america and then
here is where
even with all of that trump would
probably snipe it at elon but here is
where trump felt he had to snipe it at
elon
elon said if desantis runs against biden
in 2024 then desantis will easily win he
doesn't even need to campaign
now i dis i disagree with that
perception not because of any weakness
of desantis just because of how corrupt
the liberal establishment is
so i i agree with elon musk desantis
would be i think a phenomenal candidate
no question about that he's a phenomenal
governor
but would he wouldn't even have to
campaign i don't buy that for a second i
think they would they would do the same
thing to desantis that they did to trump
that they did to bush that they did to
reagan that they do to all of them and
they'd say he's a nazi and he's a rapist
and he's a racist and he is a pedophile
and he
he probably punched his grandmother in
the face you know they would they would
throw the kitchen sink at him
so trump now is punching back at elon
the reason he's punching at elon too
it's not even it's not even just about
desantis
it's about anyone saying anything nice
about any republican candidate other
than donald trump trump at this moment
knows that he's on the top of the heap
he knows that the nomination is his
basically if he wants it and so he's got
to make it very painful for anybody to
endorse any other candidate he's got to
make it very painful for anybody to
boost or raise money for any other
candidate whether that's ron desantis
whether it's ted cruz whether it's josh
hawley whether it's rand paul whether
it's nikki haley whether it's
pompeo whether it's whoever
that's what this is about and it's
unclear right now
could
could ron desantis
or someone else but desantis seems to be
top of the heap right now could he mount
a successful primary campaign against
trump
i'm not sure i'm not sure
right now i lean toward
no
but maybe that could change desantis has
been on a rocket ship of success and
name recognition and goodwill in the
republican party recently maybe he could
maybe he couldn't but one thing i know
for sure is republicans want to avoid a
bloody messy primary contest between
desantis and trump especially because
trump fights so dirty
they don't want to see the golden boy
governor of florida who's doing such a
great job destroyed because of this
bitter contest for president
now it gets even more interesting than
all of that
because of a figure not in state
government not in the federal government
not a former president
because of a tv show host
a tv show host
who is just
just for some reason going to be taking
a trip
to iowa
so this show has come to iowa for a
couple days giving a speech at the
family leadership summit in des moines
lots of people who are running for
president are swinging through iowa we
thought we would assess the field we're
going to stream that speech live on fox
nation tomorrow friday 5 pm eastern go
to fucksnation.com for access tucker is
such a pro the guy is so smart
listen to those words which were
scripted those were in a teleprompter he
chose those words very carefully he said
we're swinging through iowa
our eyebrows go up
he says yeah i'll be given a speech so
it's not just that he's doing interviews
it's not just these covering it on the
ground he's giving a speech to an
important conservative summit our
eyebrows go up even further
and then just in case anybody missed
what he's putting out there he said
lots of people who are running for
president
are making tours through iowa right now
giving speeches that sort of thing
and then he gives himself the out a
little plausible deniability he says so
we're just here surveying the field
oh we're just here doing journalism
but i'm also given a speech
and i'm giving a speech with the other
people who are maybe running for
president
a lot of people have called for tucker
to run for president i think he could
mount a pretty serious campaign not
saying he would win the nomination
necessarily but he could mount a pretty
serious campaign and then it occurred to
me
he could mount possibly the greatest
campaign in the country
for vice president
especially if trump is the nominee
if trump is the nominee who is he going
to pick for vice president obviously
it's not going to be mike pence
i guess it could be could be ted cruz
i don't know again yeah it's a little
awkward because i host a show with uh
senator cruz i have not spoken to him
about this at all this is just purely my
own conjecture but i i guess i could see
that
the united states senator so it kind of
balances things out nikki haley i could
see nikki haley worked for
donald trump she brings in a little bit
more of the moderate side of the party
though she did irritate some trump
voters when she went after him in
politico but then she kind of she said
that this didn't represent my actual
views about trump and so i don't know
she might be able to do that
maybe i don't know maybe a pompeo i
don't think a desantis really could i
just think desantis and trump are too
similar they they have they've had
roles that are too similar in government
their personalities are a little bit too
similar
i don't see desantis taking a vice
president i don't i don't see trump
offering it to him but
tucker that
there's a lot of ideological overlap
between the two men
they come from totally different parts
of politics trump from
from the executive from actually being
the president tucker brings in the media
he's the most popular conservative tv
show
host and yet there's a lot of overlap
there too between the guys
both have a big background in the media
world trump really respects guys who
come from the media trump endorsed dr oz
i think primarily because dr oz had a tv
show
just very interesting stuff i don't know
exactly what's going to happen but
that could be
there could be a kind of natural
spot if tucker wanted if tucker went
crazy and wanted to give up his
extremely lucrative very influential
post on television to go join the melee
of elected politics
that's what's going on in iowa speaking
of the midwest
there's an update to that horrible story
and
kind of sketchy story about
a child who was raped in in ohio and
then
went to indiana to get an abortion and
the story was first reported on by a
very pro-abortion activist doctor and
she wouldn't give any details and it was
dodgy and she said she didn't meet this
patient but she got a call from a doctor
who knew a person who got the patient
and
joe biden pushed this and it was all
really part of an
anti-anti-pro-life pro-abortion argument
that the left was making the attorney
general of ohio couldn't find details on
the crime no one was offering any
details then some days later
some reports about a crime that seemed
similar cropped up and there was a girl
who was not quite the same age but
almost that age that it was being
reported on and
then it came out later that the man who
raped her was an illegal immigrant 27
year old illegal alien so that could
have explained why the story was being
reported in such a weird way because the
media didn't want to divulge these
details because it cuts against their
immigration narrative well now it's
getting even dodgier a telemundo
reporter maria vargas-pione went to the
home
of this girl and really the girl's
mother and tried to interview her to get
more details because the story
just doesn't really totally add up the
mother would not open the door
and contradicted
pretty much all the reports about the
rape
reporter says did the girl live here as
well
mother says yes but she's fine
everything that they're saying against
him is a lie
the child are you related to her the
mother
she's my daughter she says the woman
refused to provide her name show her
face she said she's not filed charges
against the 20 year old gerson fuentes
who is charged with the rape
according to the authorities he
confessed
to having a vaginal contact on at least
two occasions with the girl who recently
turned ten so he did this when she was
9.
when she was raped and then became
pregnant
really really
crazy story because
people are
inferring from this
that i think justifiably i think it
pretty inarguably that the
mother knows the
the accused rapist maybe the accused
rapist was the boyfriend maybe the
accused rapist was living with them
maybe the accused rapist was very close
and so she's saying yeah the girl's fine
don't worry about it yeah she was raped
by them
she whether she was raped or not forget
about that she's fine he's he's
wonderful don't charge him with any
crimes he's a great guy and so now we're
seeing this as uh
very possibly just a case of a horrible
horrible family of
of uh illegal aliens that this
mother and potentially a boyfriend or a
relative or someone that at least is
known to the mother endangering the
welfare of this poor little girl it
becomes a much different story than what
was initially
reported now
one of the questions that has come up
tangential to this highly politicized
ohio rape case
is what should be the punishment for
rape
the mother of the poor little girl is
saying no don't punish the guy he's fine
it's all a lie he's great don't worry
about it so that's obviously sickening
it somehow makes the story even more
repulsive
some people are saying the penalty for
rape certainly rape of a child should be
the death penalty
and i think
i understand why people have that
natural reaction but this is this is an
example of even conservatives thinking
too much with their emotions and not
thinking enough with their logic and
their reason and their minds
i got into a debate with a number of
conservatives over this
i'm all for the death penalty i think
the death penalty should be more widely
applied in society
but i'm opposed to the death penalty for
rape and the reason for this is not
because the rapists don't deserve it
they certainly deserve death
but because of incentives
if the punishments for rape and the
punishments for murder are the same
punishments
then
the rapist has an incentive to murder
his victim because if he murders his
victim he will reduce the likelihood
that he is caught but he will not
increase
the risk of punishment that he has
whereas if the punishment for rape is
less than the punishment for murder he
at least has some incentive not to
murder his victim by not murdering his
victim yes his risk of being caught will
increase
but his risk of punishment will
decrease and decrease pretty
dramatically if we're talking about the
death penalty this is an area where the
libs are always discarding their reason
and their logic and their minds and and
making political decisions with their
emotions and their will
conservatives sometimes are liable to do
this too
you've got to ask yes it might feel
emotionally satisfying to say death
penalty for these rapists
yes it's it is even true to say that
rapists deserve the death penalty
but what's going to be better for the
victims what's going to serve the cause
of justice better
seems to me in this case it's pretty
clear that the the penalty has to be a
little bit lower or else all you're
going to do you might feel a little bit
better but all you're going to do is
incentivize
monsters to
be even worse to their victims and to
punish their victims even
even more
speaking of child abuse the cdc
is encouraging your kids to visit
groomer chat websites
and hide it from you
from their parents i'm not joking it
sounds like a sensational headline it's
really not the center for disease
control is promoting two young people an
online chat space that discusses sex
polyamorous relationships sex change
operations activism
and the occult
it's a little bit of a sidebar but isn't
it weird how whenever you go far enough
down
the leftist especially the sexual
revolution leftist activism you end up
at overt satanism
isn't that weird even drag queen story
hour why do the drag queens dress up
like demons
frequently
why do why does the pro-abortion
activism often take on
explicitly satanic imagery
why does why do
why does
leftist activism take on the language of
witchcraft or spells or the occult why
does that happen
almost as though there's a spiritual
reality to all of this and certainly at
a practical level we have to ask why is
the cdc promoting creepy weird sex stuff
and the occult to little kids on
websites the website is called q chat
that that have buttons that you can make
it that make it much easier for the
children to hide the websites for the
parents if the parents walk by
the chat hosts conversations on topics
such as drag culture 101 sex and
relationships having multiple genders by
slash pan youth a gender affirmation
surgeries hormone therapy self-discovery
in astrology and queering tarot tarot
the the weird occult cards
not tarot seems bad enough but then
they're going to queer tarot as well
why why that one
this reminds us that there is no
neutrality here the government is going
to be pushing some set of values or
another and
either they're going to be pushing
the devil's values like this tarot and
queering the occult and chop off your
genitals five-year-olds or they're going
to be pushing good true
virtuous values your pick i think we the
conservatives need to stop throwing our
hands in the air and pretending this is
all neutral and enforce our vision of
the good all political
life involves promoting some vision of
the good and discouraging some vision of
the bad and so we ought to do the
correct one not this creepy one
but it it is a reminder too
i've mentioned this a few times in
recent weeks it's the iq bell curve meme
really dumb people who are drooling who
just duh they don't know anything about
politics they say i think the bad stuff
is because of the devil and the good
stuff you know good stuff is about god
right and then the people in the middle
it's like well actually you know those
are all just metaphors and uh what it's
really about is um the uh
marxism and post-modernism and this ism
and that ism and it's a really just the
metaphor of your inner blah blah blah
and then you get to the people who are
really smart at like the thomas aquinas
end of the iq spectrum and they say no
it's about god
and the rejection of god in that is
personified in the devil who is a real
person by the way who you can worship
but you shouldn't worship that's what
it's really about it's why it always
comes down to this this is why the
weirdos on tick-tock who are trying to
trans your kids is why they always look
like demons and the more they get into
it the more they look like demons and
they wear they have explicit satanic
imagery on there
maybe instead of dismissing all of that
and saying oh we're so we know none of
that exists how about we look at all of
human history in all cultures and say
how come they all have a conception of
god and a conception of the devil
isn't that kind of weird maybe there's
some wisdom in that that we should pay
attention to speaking of
computers
and
naughty things that you shouldn't do
a really interesting story almost
entirely unrelated here about artificial
intelligence but it's really going to
affect students and teachers in our
education system there's a university of
kansas professor john simons who's
pointing out that this this coming
school year in particular
you're going to see a major
technological revolution when it comes
to writing papers
and it's because artificial intelligence
is now good enough that ai can write
papers for students that are b plus a
minus papers and they can't be caught by
the plagiarism software so in recent
years if a student submits a plagiarized
paper there's just checking software you
can run the paper you say okay 80 of
this paper is plagiarized you get an f
but now because of artificial
intelligence you don't just need to
plagiarize they can write a new paper
without having the student actually have
to write it and
the professor makes a good point it's a
point that we've made on this show
before
what's the solution to this
the only solution to this
is going to be to minimize the role of
technology in
in education the only solution to this
is to get rid of the zoom get rid of the
uh submit your papers online get rid of
the do everything from a remote distance
whether it's
in your parents basement or whether it's
from your dorm room it's going to have
to increase the amount of in-person
learning you're going to have to
minimize the number of papers and
increase the number of oral exams
because you can't use artificial
intelligence on an oral exam and this
would be a really really good thing so
many of our political issues way beyond
education come down to the isolation of
man from the real world and we're living
our lives virtually it explains a lot of
the transgender stuff you talk to people
who've gone down the transgender rabbit
hole
most of them it seems to me at least in
my experience have been radicalized
online
in these online communities and that
makes perfect sense because online your
body doesn't matter
you're just a free-floating mind and you
have avatars in a virtual space
so much of our lives the way we work now
we telecommute a lot of people tell it i
don't but a lot of people telecommute a
lot of people do e-distance learning
where your body doesn't matter as much
and it alienates you from the world and
it makes society a lot worse and it's
depressing and it's inhuman if we want
to restore a more flourishing society we
got to put the body back into it
salvation hinges on the flesh
it has been said
and so much of civilization hinges on
the flesh too we got to see people in
real life and hug them not through weird
bulletproof glass like they made us do
during covid we got to hug real people
in real life and go have dinner with
them in real life and go learn from real
professors in real life and go work with
people together in real life we've got
to be
human again or
this is just
necessarily the case we will lose
our very humanity
you know rather than waste this weekend
watching another mediocre production
maybe you ought to check out
daily wire plus daily wire plus is
everything you love about the daily wire
plus so much more we are continuing to
build our content library with movies
and shows that are engaging entertaining
and thought-provoking such as mount
walsh's what is a woman
is gina carano's summer blockbuster tara
on the prairie
they're wonderful documentaries such as
fouchy unmasked my favorite documentary
vouchy unmasked here's jordan peterson's
new four-part series dragons monsters
and men imagine that shows and movies
that you actually want to see it's time
to build the future you want become a
member at
dailywireplus.com for a limited time you
can get 35 off your new membership with
code plus that is dailywireplus.com
we will be right back with the voicemail
bag
welcome back to my absolute favorite
time of the week the mailbag sponsored
by puretalk go to puretalk.com select a
plan and enter promo code knowles
podcast to save 50 off your first month
off the already great price which is
going to save you what two-thirds on
your cell phone bill it's a great deal
in and of itself but most importantly it
will keep the voicemail back on the air
so head on over there pure talk right
now all right first question
hi obligatory introduction saying thank
you for what you do love it
so i'm reading speechless by the great
nostradamus it has obviously provided a
lot of fodder for thought and dinner
table conversations with the fam
one phrase in the book struck me as
particularly thought provoking is
a humility parade would seem
self-defeating this is in reference to
pride parades
thankfully june turned out really good
for us conservatives but you know
there's still stuff that we disagree
with going on
anyway my question is this how do we
oppose pride and not exclusively gay
pride just the sin of pride that's uh
you know
rampant in our society
with humility which is the opposite of
pride
while managing to remain humble so what
does this look like in daily life
thanks again bye
you've got to keep your eyes on god
that's what it's about instead of
thinking about yourself and how to even
think about yourself should i think
should i be confident should i
should i think of all the good stuff
i've done should i think of all the sins
that i commit should i think about what
i did yesterday should i think about
what i did 10 years ago instead of
that
just turn the focus off of yourself
entirely and you've got to put your
focus entirely on god which will
accomplish all of those things it will
remind you that you do have an inherent
worth because you're made in the image
and likeness of god if you were looking
at the cross looking at your crucified
lord on the cross you will recognize
that you have worth because god himself
god the son died for your sins it will
also remind you that you are a sinner
you're not all that man you there's a
reason that god had to come down to
earth to die for your sins
that
will remind you
of your flaws and your worth and all of
those things and it will just kind of
just click everything
into the right place and then you have
to do these you have to
do these good things in the world that
you want to do and and
you need to pursue virtue not just for
yourself but because your focus is in
the right place next question
hey michael thanks for taking my
question i've listened to the show for a
few years have always enjoyed
the be a man advice and the constant
reminder to get a girlfriend before a
dog
but following that i've moved to indiana
but stayed in illinois to finish my
associate's degree
and i've taken an interest in this girl
and i don't want to lead her on for a
relationship
because i'm leaving for indiana at the
end of august
so i don't really see a point in dating
right now but i would like to
take her out to see a movie see
that she wants to see how would i go
about starting this friendship without
it morphing into something more uh thank
you for taking my question and look
forward to the advice
you don't that's how you don't do that
if you you're asking me how do i take a
girl out on a date without taking her
out on a date you can't that's not
possible
you
obviously are interested in this girl
that's why you want to go on a date with
her
but you don't want to
lead her on because i guess you're not
interested in her enough to try to
pursue a longer relationship
so you just need to make a decision
you need to make a decision and stick to
that decision you're trying to have your
cake and eat it too and that's not going
to work you can since you alluded to it
at the top
act like a man what's the matter with
you now i will tell you if it were me i
don't know all the details of your
particular situation if it were me
i would take the girl on a date and
maybe try to discern if we're going to
have some love affair here and if it's
going to blossom into a marriage and
we're going to have 10 kids and have a
great life together i know that you're
planning out every step in your life
well and then i'm going to move here and
so it's not going to work and then i'm
going to get this job and then we're
going to go here and then i'm going to
do this and you're trying to be really
rationalistic about the whole thing but
no you like the girl the girl likes you
you want to go on a date
maybe you end up moving but maybe you
keep the relationship going a little bit
long distance and then you try to work
out a way for you to both end up in the
same place together that's what i would
do if it were me
but if you for sure say nope not gonna
do it we're not gonna date long term
then don't take her out on a date now
don't you you're asking me how do i how
do i lead a girl on without leading her
on you can't so then you gotta just
write that off and she's gonna go see a
movie with another guy next question hey
michael my name's chris i'm 17 and i'm a
resident of central florida after
fleeing ontario canada last november
i'm a big fan of the daily wire and i've
heard almost all of the main
personalities share their opposition to
red flag laws which i'm also opposed to
my only confusion is with the proposed
alternatives i've heard that the mass
shooters that seemed unstable before
committing the shootings should have
been institutionalized which i'm not
opposed to but my issue comes up with
the fact that if we're able to lock
people up in mental facilities against
their will for seeming dangerous
couldn't the government use this
institutionalization as a tactic in the
same way they might use red flag laws
thanks again big fan
really good question
the answer is yes but not exactly in the
same way and this is why a lot of people
who oppose things like red flag laws
and oppose things like most gun control
measures also support increasing the
ease with which people can be
institutionalized because you've just
got to make the threshold very very high
the problem with red flag laws is the
threshold for depriving people of their
constitutional and civil rights is very
very low the way democrats talk about
red flag was the red flag is you
listening to this show is a red flag
voting for donald trump is a red flag
having an american flag outside of your
home is a red flag it's the red white
and blue flag and they're going to take
away your guns
so that threshold is so low and it's so
vague
to
involuntarily commit someone to an
insane asylum the threshold has to be at
least relatively high
now it's so high that it's virtually
impossible i think we should lower that
threshold a little bit but it's still
going to be very very high and it forces
you to grapple with the reality of what
it means to deprive someone of their
second amendment rights when you deprive
someone of their second amendment rights
which is a a basic right a
constitutional right a civil right and
the right to self-defense is a natural
right
you are saying i must deprive you you of
all of your rights because you are not
able to exercise them at all you are not
able to live your life as a normal human
being so your you're really making that
clear
and for some people that's true people
who are insane people who are not able
to take care of themselves sure okay
that we already have laws in the books
for this right relatives can exercise
power of attorney if an if a loved one
say becomes senile or
otherwise incapacitated so we already
have ways to do this
but it's a way of saying okay you want
to take away my rights well then take
away my rights to really take away my
rights because
if not if you're not willing to do that
if you're not willing to lock me up in a
straight jacket then let me have my guns
let me have my right to self-defense
don't don't pull a little bait and
switch here well
you're not crazy enough that we're going
to take care of you or really change
your lifestyle at all but you are so
crazy that we we need to deprive you of
your really really basic rights that's
that that's the game that the libs are
trying to play right now we want to
clarify the the stakes next question
hi mr knowles
i have a philosophical and theological
question about the so-called god of the
gaps logical fallacy
i was thinking about it earlier and i
realized i can't make any sense of it
anymore
you've mentioned on the show that st
thomas aquinas teaches that god is
reason and will and that his reason and
will do not come into conflict
the god of the gaps posits that anything
we can't explain by reason we cheat and
ascribe to god's will
this is supposed to show that god is a
psychological condition
but it just assumes that reason is
separate from god
and then makes this incomplete version
of god a psychological condition
am i missing something about this
argument or does it really basically
assume its conclusion
and then as a sort of bonus question i
was wondering if you could
speak to this concept of moving an idea
from
god's will to god's reason and what we
can say about that as catholics
thank you
sure actually both questions kind of tie
into the same place when people use the
phrase god of the gaps
usually they're not using it in the way
that nietzsche meant the phrase for
instance they're using it in the way
that
edgy online atheists from the mid-2000s
used it and journalists who were part of
the new atheist movement used it which
is to say that god is opposed to reason
and what this reveals is that these
people just know it very little about
god they know absolutely nothing about
religion they haven't read any of the
works that they're purporting to be
experts on
because in christianity at least
god is
logic god it's right there in john
chapter one in the beginning was the
logos the divine logic of the universe
the word and the word was with god and
the word was god
this there are differences between
religions here uh pope benedict uh the
16th in his regensburg address probably
the greatest address of the 21st century
described a big difference with islam in
islam according to islam allah is pure
will allah is is so utterly transcendent
that he's pure will allah could order
his subjects to violate logic to worship
idols even and they would be bound to do
that where in christianity god is logic
so that would be
the one difference there the phrase god
of the gaps can have some use
to make fun of bad theology to make fun
of faulty theology to make fun of
shallow religion but god of the gaps
does not does not describe
christianity
to orthodox traditional christianity
read thomas aquinas i guarantee you none
of these people have read thomas aquinas
read thomas aquinas and say that man's
not logical i an edgy online atheist i
am much more logical than thomas aquinas
give me a break it's ridiculous so uh
that that would be the issue and so when
you ask how do we move from a
conversation about god as will to god as
logic and reason well you have to
recognize
those are unified in god
the logic and the power are unified and
and will and power are unified in god as
well this is what
dante writes in the mouth of virgil when
virgil and dante are about to cross into
hell and caron the the boatman doesn't
want to let him in because he says dante
you're a living person you don't you're
not allowed to come into hell and it's
one of the most famous lines of the
comedy virgil says
which is a great line if you want to
memorize it in italian it's it's very
funny because it means this is willed
where will and power are united and
don't ask any more questions
this is this is desired where people can
where where it can be done what is
willed and so you stop shut up stop
asking questions let me into the boat
and so in god all of all of that is
unified
not just desire and power
but desire power and logic and reason
okay let's get to a written mailbag
question from bailly michael i have a
question about guilt and forgiveness in
my youth i was not a good person isn't
that that's true of all of us every i
probably
99.7 of people could say that uh okay
bailey says i started drinking and
smoking at 16 years old and slept around
i became addicted to pain killers and
began smoking weed daily at 18 years old
my high school boyfriend did the same it
was an alcoholic we were together from
age 16 until i got pregnant at 23 the
moment i found out i quit everything my
daughter's three now me and her father
split shortly after she was born i've
met an amazing christian man god save
got married and we have a one month old
son my problem is i deal with so much
guilt my daughter now has a broken home
just like the one i grew up in her
father gets her every other weekend
while my son has both parents at home my
husband treats her like his own but i
constantly i think constantly about how
unfair it is to my daughter and have a
terrible time forgiving myself for who i
used to be how do i get past this thanks
and love the show sincerely reformed
degenerate
well
not all of the saints started well but
they all ended well that's a line from
saint john vianney and you think maybe
most famously of saint augustine who had
a pretty wild sinful youth he even has
that great line that he prayed which is
lord make me chaste but not yet
and he
slept around and did all sorts of bad
things that he shouldn't have been doing
and then he reformed and this is true of
not just regular run-of-the-mill good
old people but some of the greatest
saints in history they didn't all start
well but they all ended well you're
asking me a very practical question
about your conscience which is nagging
you and and so i'm going to give you a
technical answer and i don't know if
it's going to work for you or not well i
do know if it'll work for you but i
don't know
how you will
perceive it because i don't know if
you're catholic or not but you know my
my views on these things obviously come
from a catholic view of the world and so
i think that
the the way to receive absolution and
the way even at a psychological level to
assuage your nagging conscience is to go
to sacramental confession
and so i don't i don't know if you're
catholic or not or if you're interested
in becoming catholic or if you believe
in the sacraments or you believe in
confession or any of those sorts of
things but that would just be the
technical answer i have found that
really has worked for me i think it is
totally legit i 100 believe in that
at a kind of broader level than just
that technical answer you're asking
how can i forgive myself for my past
more generally and i think you've got to
again look not at your own person but
look at god who who forgives you who
sends his son to die on the cross for
the forgiveness of your sins and so if
god can forgive you
you should be able to as well i know
that practically is not always easy to
do but part of that stems from pride
it's very presumptuous to say oh well
forgiving me yeah that's you know that's
fine for god but i'm holding myself to a
higher standard oh are you
don't you think that's a little
presumptuous i i think it is as well you
cannot change the past
the past is gone you cannot do anything
in the past i know we all want to and we
think about it and depending on how
anxious a person you are you you might
be nagged by some comment that you made
10 years ago to some random person i
know that we dwell on the past the devil
wants you to dwell on the past because
you can't do anything in the past and so
you become impotent and you become
depressed and you despair you can only
do things in the present could life have
worked out better for you and your kid
and your ex-boyfriend
had you all done things all differently
when you were younger
maybe maybe i guess so
i'm not totally sure about that in the
way in the unfolding of providence but
maybe they could have but
that is totally beside the point all you
can decide to do is what are the
decisions that are presented to you
today
all the only place you can live is in
the present you can't even live in the
future a lot of people want to live in
the future too you can't you can only
live in the present so all you can do is
do the right thing
and harping on your past incessantly
particularly if you have taken the steps
to get over that psychological spiritual
everything in between
harping on the past is a waste of your
time it's worse than a waste of your
time you'll be neglecting the things you
ought to be doing right now so story
it's not unique to you i think most
people they not they don't have the
particulars of your of your circumstance
but most people
have a similar story and uh it's a it's
a common problem for human beings
the solution to that is to accept god's
forgiveness accept that grace which you
you're free to turn away from that grace
but i don't recommend it and then
do the right thing in the present which
is where you live i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show see you
next week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode new
details emerge about the rape of a
ten-year-old in ohio whose abortion
story made national headlines a seismic
demographic shift is taking place in
both political parties and unvaccinated
novak djokovic wins wimbledon but is
still barred from the u.s open join us
and get the facts first on the news you
need to know with our show morning wire